[MUSIC]
to introduce Madhusudan
Parthasarathy who's visiting
us from Illinois, University
of Illinois Urbana-Champaign.
He's been doing research in
logics and decision procedures
for program verification,
building verified systems.
Of late he's doing synthesis,
and
there's a machine learning
thing for invariance.
So today he's gonna talk
about natural proofs and
quantifier instantiation.
>> Okay, so
I'm gonna talk about this work
which the results
are fairly new.
So the slides are raw, and
the result's also a bit raw
in the sense that we probably
haven't understood consequences
of the results completely to
present it in a nice way.
Okay, so with that caveat,
this is joint work with Christof
Loding at RWTH and Lucas Pena,
who's student at
University of Illinois.
So I'm gonna be sticking to
this verification context,
this deductive verification.
The problem is you
have a program,
let's say with assertions,
that you wanna prove correct.
And the method we're going to
follow is annotated with strong
enough inductive pre and post
conditions and loop invariants.
And then we generate
verification
conditions which involve
loop free code and
this will mean the underlying
logic can vary.
And then we want to
validate the verification
conditions using a logic solver.
So what logic do we use for
these specifications?
Actually there's quite
a lot of choices.
The first kind of logics that
come to mind are first order
logics.
But as we will see,
this is not quite enough.
But traditionally if you really
want to automate everything,
then you would like the
verification conditions to be
essentially in
a decidable logic.
And so
if it's quantifier free or
are the logics that
are desirable,
then that will be fully
automatable and the idea is that
this qualifier free logics
with some background theories.
Especially if they're quantifier
free then they are combinable.
If they meet some conditions,
they're combinable using those.
And that gives you a wide
variety of theories that you
could use and build decision
procedures that are kind
of independent of each other.
Now that attraction of decidable
logics is that verification
after annotation is
fully automated.
And that is actually quite
useful, because when you
are actually verifying, you know
that you will either get back,
well, time is one thing.
But you'll get back
either an error, or
it won't just keep on searching.
If it keeps on searching, then I
don't know whether it's actually
maybe I wrote something wrong.
And there's a little bit
of uncertainty when you use
the verification tool when you
don't have decidable objects.
But I think where decidability
can also be a trap.
We need powerful enough logics
to do program verification.
And I think,
at least the natural logics
that we can use to express
properties that we
wanna prove will turn
out to be undecidable.
So for
instance we do need quantifiers.
We need logics
perhaps over certain
theories that are undecidable.
And typically currently, I would
say, the reasons why we need
more expressive power than
desirable logics are the state
properties about unbounded parts
of your program configuration,
like arrays and
data structures, and
the dynamically changing heap.
Or to express, and even if you
kind of go away from this by
assuming certain libraries,
which manipulate state.
And keep these structures for
you, in some abstract way,
you still need to argue about
sequences, stats, functions,
pure recursive functions of
your data structure and so on.
And these are typically
not going to
be in decidable periods.
So there is this obsession
with decidability, and
I've been part of that.
We've been trying to work with
decidable logics as much as
possible.
And decidability, as I said,
when achievable is very good.
It gives you predictability.
It also gives you engineering
of efficient tools because you
can have competitions.
And you don't have
things which I
think it's a little harder to
have competition if on some
things you are going
to fail even proving.
I think it kind of directs the
engineering task better when you
know it's a decidable problem.
>> So decidability doesn't
mean efficiency, right?
>> No it does not,
it's more like a heuristic for
building better tools.
It kind of guides you.
And we have found that
to be the case that
over time we've got better
solvers with decidable logics.
We don't know how these
mechanics work, but
it seems to be true.
>> Can we say that the provers
operate in a more predictable
way on deciding these fragments?
>> Yeah, I think predictability.
>> Can we quantify that?
>> I don't know.
I don't know if you
can quantify that.
>> Temperatures are predictable.
>> [LAUGH] Well it depends on
what you call predictable.
I think you have a lower bar for
predictability than
what that we've meant.
[LAUGH]
>> Let's just talk about
variance.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
it the variance greater
on a collection of?
If you keep doing runs
with different random
on undecidable [INAUDIBLE].
>> So this agenda of building
decidable theories, the ultimate
question is, can we, over time,
really obtain a powerful enough
decidable logic using which we
can prove all that we need to?
And I think that
question is not clear.
Everyone makes an epsilon step,
does one more decidable logic
which is slightly more powerful.
It's not clear where this
whole thing is headed.
So in my view,
the answer seems to be no.
I don't think we
are heading towards
the wonderful decidable
logics that will solve all
the verification
problems [INAUDIBLE].
>> I think your last slide it's
not the slight [INAUDIBLE] but
they're often incomparable.
>> They're incomparable as well.
Well typically you
kind of branch out.
Maybe then comparable and
then it'll kind of merge and
sometimes you do get
reasonably robust things.
>> I'm not even sure
what this means.
You're saying you want
a decidable logic for
your verification conditions,
but
the verification conditions
depends on the proof you do.
>> Yes.
>> And so you're really saying
you want to be able to get your
proof by some manual steps down
to the decidable fragment as
easily as possible.
In which case you can never
really say you solved
the problem.
You just say it gets easier and
easier.
>> Right, but yeah, so
I'm being vague here so
I hope that's okay.
I'm not making any
concrete statements,
I'm just trying to
motivate natural proofs,
which is a different way
of looking at things.
So the statements I
make are gonna be
a little vague at this point.
Okay, so we worked on
decidable logics for
heaps for a long time and
we had this logical strand and
there'd been lots of logics for
heaps.
And their logics are also based
on separation logics for heaps.
Several decidable
fragments have emerged.
But I don't see the spark
towards a powerful enough logic,
which is also decidable.
So, two things which I
notice is that, as you
get more and more expressive in
your logic, the constraints that
you need to put in your syntax
become more and more awkward.
You're not just given
a set of operators and
say combine whatever you want.
You should have some
bizarre conditions that
need to be satisfied.
The second thing which I find
is more troubling is that
the decision procedures get
more and more complex, right?
By that I mean that
even if you had something which
you could solve earlier, right?
It is true that the new decision
procedure which handles a larger
logic, right.
It takes much longer
to that same problem,
that same instance, right?
So the general way of
solving something, right?
Makes the procedures tend
to work slower, okay?
They have to solve a larger
class of problems more uniformly
and so you get, at least in
our experience [INAUDIBLE]
you start using all kinds
of background things,
like monadic second order logic,
and stuff like that.
Stitching these things up to
get more expressiveness, and
then they work really badly on
even simple instances, right?
And I think one should remember
that decidability is a heuristic
here, automation is the goal,
decidability is not the goal,
right?
So here's the other
way of looking at it,
which I've been working on for
several years.
The idea in decidable logics is
that you want to curtail your
expressive power of your logic
so that it becomes automatable.
We automate reasonining.
Now natural proofs,
the idea is different.
It's that you allow a logic
to be quite powerful, right?
You might restrict the style,
but
you don't typically restrict
the expressive power, right?
But in order to
automate what you do,
is you look for
a sub class of proofs, right?
And these proofs are going to
be simpler to search for, right?
And if you find a simple
proof for your theorem,
you're gonna say,
yes, I found it.
And if you don't find a proof,
then it's not gonna work,
so you're gonna give up, right?
So these are more like sound,
in complete ways, right,
of solving problems, right?
But we like to build robust
classes nevertheless and
possibly even
a hierarchy of classes.
I look for the simplest proofs
and if I don't find it,
I enlarge my, the class
of proofs I search for.
So two things here.
Logic doesn't get awkward,
right,
you write what you want,
given the style.
And the proofs are not going to
get complex because we're kind
of searching for
simple proofs only.
>> So when you say if you
have a rolling class,
does that mean the user's
involved with the proof?
>> No.
>> So you're not gonna interact
>> No, so,
typically you search for a
simple proof, you don't find it.
Like, quantifier
instantiation is one, right?
You could quantify more, right?
You could instantiate more,
right?
>> That's the natural proof of-
>> So when you say a simple
proof, does it mean the simpler
the proof is, the easier it is
for the user to sort of have
confidence in the proof, or-
>> No, it's just that decision
wise, it's simple to search for
a proof of that type, right?
The complexity of searching for
a proof of that kind is-
>> But
that would depend on
the search right?
>> True. Right.
But
it's gonna be
a subclass of proofs.
I think that's the main thing,
right?
Okay so we've been working on
natural proofs for some time and
this is not practice as in
industry practice, right?
It's basically trying to
make this work on a set of
benchmarks.
So what we have settled on
is really first order logic
with recursive definitions and
background theories.
And we've found that this
is good enough to express
properties about heaps.
So we have a dialect of
separation logic called dryad
that compiles into this logic.
Right, I don't know how to do
automation on separation logic
or other logics directly.
I know only classical logic, so
I'm going to stick
to classical logic.
Right, so but we do have
more than first order logic.
We do have first order logic
with recursive definitions,
right?
And the heuristics
that we use to prove
a theorem are what we found
in practice people do.
If you give it manually
to a person to prove it,
what tactics would they use?
And typically what they use
in the world of recursive
definition is, unfold these
recursive definitions.
Right, typically a few times,
right?
And then they do some kind
of unification, right?
At the level of term rewriting,
you can think of
this as unification.
But it's basically,
you can kind of mimic this as
interpreting the recursive
definitions that you have as
uninterpreted functions, right?
That kind of mimics the
unification things that they do.
So we looked at proofs of how
people normally prove things and
the simple proofs
are really based on this.
This was enough to prove
most of the things.
And so
the resulting formula is, so
what we do is basically unfold
the recursive definitions.
If I have a recursive
definition for list,
I will just unfold it
a few times, right.
And then I would basically
interpret the recursive
definitions as
unintegrated functions.
And I'm in a refutation
based context.
So I'm looking at a formula and
trying to prove it's valid
by showing its negation
is unsatisfiable.
So if doing this already gives
me an unsatisfiable formula,
I'm done because I've shown
that the theorem is valid.
So I don't need to
actually unfold.
And to use an abstraction,
but that abstraction is fine and
kind of mimics what people do.
Moreover, the resulting formulas
are actually in decidable
theories.
Right, so you can unfold and
then send it off
to an SMT solver.
By the way, this is not at all,
that only we do,
everyone essentially does this.
Natural proofs is
more like a name for
talking about this in some way.
Daphne does it.
If you have recursive
definitions in Daphne which
are pure functions, Daphne
unfolds these functions and
gives it to assembly solver.
Everyone does it.
>> The simplicity is
measured by [INAUDIBLE],
is that the definition?
>> I think the simplicity
is got to do with,
yeah you could think
about it that way.
But it's basically the fact that
you are abstracting from what
you wanna prove and
thereby you are looking for
a simpler proof that
that thing holds.
So if you don't succeed in this
doesn't mean that it doesn't
hold, you don't get concrete
counter examples or
anything like that, right?
Maybe that the theorem
is false or
maybe it need to do more, right?
>> So one way maybe to think
about this is cooling for
something for
an object with the heat.
How much of the rest of heat do
you really care about, right?
>> Right, so
the variant of actually has it,
it forces you to write
recursive definition so
that you don't rely on
something very far away.
Right.
So typically because of data
structures you can have
the quantification restritc
in a guarded fashion.
So it refers to something you
already have in your hand,
right?
And so
Dryad actually does all that.
So make sure that you don't do
arbitrary quantifications so
that they are more amenable
to recursive proofs,
inductive proofs.
So here's an example, so I have
the definition of a list here,
right.
Either it's nil and
heaplet of this list is empty,
I don't really need this.
But all the excess not nil.
And the next element to x is
a list and x does not belong to
the heaplet contained in this
list, in the next of list.
So this is the way you would
do in separation logic, right?
I'm just writing it
using first-order logic.
And hlist is defined
using again recursion, so
either the empty side of x is
nill or it's x union this.
Now, this turns out to
properly define list, right?
If hlist, however, makes sense
only if x points to your list.
Otherwise, you shouldn't use it,
it may be spurious, right.
But the intended
semantics is the least fixed
point semantics, right.
So we need first-order logic
with these fixed point to
express these kind of
properties, right.
And we are using background
theories here it sets, right.
I'm using union and
so on, right?
But once I unfold things then
this will actually be in
our decidable theory because
this kind of theory of sets is
decidable.
So the question we wanted to
ask was why do these natural
proofs work so well, right?
When they do, right,
and why do they fail so
miserably on simple properties?
So they don't actually work
well all the time, okay.
There are very simple properties
on which they don't work well.
And is there any completeness
theorem we can prove about
the simple heuristic
that we have, right?
That is, if we unfolded the
definitions larger and larger,
can we prove every theorem,
for example?
Okay, so what we have now
is a set of theorems where
we can answer such questions,
all right?
So this has got to do with
quantifier instantiation, right?
Now, it turns out that unfolding
recursive definitions is really,
very similar to quantifier
instantiation done,
which is formula-driven
quantifier instantiation.
For instance, if I have this
definition of list, right?
So unfolding this for one more
time, which is next of x, right.
I want to write the definition
for next of x that is the same
as replacing x with next of
x in this definition, right?
So unfolding is really
like taking this
universally qualified variable x
and instantiating with something
else which is another
term which can be n of x.
Now, formula driven
quantify instantiation is
a common strategy for handling
universal quantification.
It's incomplete but
e-matching existed for a,
has existed for a long time.
And roughly, I'm going to follow
this instantiation strategy that
I'm going to take any terms
that I get in my formula.
I am gonna instantiate
the universal variables using
that, okay?
And that's similar to
unfolding as well.
So here are the main
contributions of this
work, right?
We explore various logics,
like pure first-order logic,
first-order logic with
background theories, and
recursive definitions.
And show the completeness
of formula-driven term
instantiations for
some of these fragments, for
fragments of these logic.
And in particular for
first-order logic with
background theories, right?
We have a fragment
called a safe fragment.
Work that admits completeness,
right?
And we can show that
the verification that we
are doing kind of falls in that
class, modular recursive
definitions, right?
Once you get rid of
recursive definitions, and
I'll tell you how, right,
it kind of falls in this class,
and this roughly explains why
natural proofs are actually so
powerful because they're
actually complete in that sense.
The second thing we have
is that we will not
have complete this results for
first-order logic with
recursive definitions.
It's clear that you cannot
build a complete procedure for
first-order logic with recursive
definitions, right. And so
we mitigate this using certain
techniques which
are related to invariant
synthesis as well, right?
And so
it seems to be
a new kind of way.
But a lot of people
have been doing this in
the theorem community already.
I think what we are doing is we
are doing it in the first-order
context, right?
So that we reduce this to
first-order reasoning for
which we can prove completeness,
okay.
So first a reminder
of classical results.
And I'm sorry if you
know this very well.
It's just that I've been with
audiences where they may not
remember it.
So first of all, first-order
logic admits sound and
complete reasoning.
This is a Godel’s
completeness thereom, right?
First-order logic is
undecidable, right?
And validity of
first-order logic is RE
because it admits a sound,
it has a complete proof system.
You know that you can
enumerate proofs and
prove any theorem in
first-order logic, right?
So validity is in RE and
satisfiability is not in RE
because it's not decidable,
all right?
And it also turns out that
recursive definitions and least
fixed point cannot be expressed
in first-order logic, right?
And there is no
complete procedure for
first-order logic with
least fixed points.
If you throw in that you can do
a non whole thing or something
and then show that you cannot
have an RE procedure for it.
And so first-order logic with
least fixed points in a full
generality, there cannot
be a complete procedure for
it, right?
You can't hope to prove
every theorem But
for first-order logic, right,
building complete definition
procedures is theoretically
possible, right?
You can just animate proofs.
And if you have your axioms, and
axioms are enumerable, right,
which they are typically,
even for
the background theories, right.
You can just keep on
enumerating proofs and
they will find it at some point,
but it's not useful in practice.
You're not gonna do this,
so we are not interested in
any enumeration which
will be complete.
It's clearly true what we
want to show is quantify
instantiation, which is
particularly useful and
seems to be particularly useful,
right?
Whether that is complete.
Now, though I just now said
it should be possible,
there's actually a fundamental
problem of doing this with
verification logics, right?
And because consider our logic
for verification conditions
that is powerful enough that
it's undecidable, okay.
Now, unlike first-order models,
the models that deal within
verification are finite and
enumerable, right.
The program configuration
is not an infinite object.
It is a finite object, right.
It can have integers, it can
have unbounded integers but
still, it's finite, right.
And any sort of finite
structures, you can enumerate.
So I can enumerate all models
which means satisfiability
of the problem and
of the logic is in RE, right.
So validity cannot be in RE,
okay?
So the fact that these models
are finite means validity
becomes harder.
Right?
And I kind of lose the lovely
thing I had in first-order
logic, that validity
is actually,
you had a complete procedure for
validity, for first-order logic.
I cannot actually take it
down to program verification. So-
>> Bug finding is very easy.
>> What was that?
>> Bug finding is easy, yes.
>> Did you?
>> So yes [LAUGH].
So this is why you can test, but
you can't verify, right?
>> So what about sequences?
Are those [INAUDIBLE]
finite models or?
>> So it all depends on
your axiomatization.
So I'm looking at only
first-order logic.
So if you would want it for
sequences,
you have axiomatize it
in first-order logic.
Could be, I mean,
an infinite axiomatization, but
it should be in recursively
enumerable one, right?
So presto arithmetic,
for example,
is a infinite axiomatization of-
>> So the model of a sequence,
is that a finite model or
is that a?
>> Yeah, I mean,
in program verification,
it's finite, right?
I'm just saying that infinite
things are actually easier
than finite things for
proving validity, right?
But we don't have
infinite things here.
So there is inherently a problem
in building complete engines for
verification.
It will come back to this.
>> [INAUDIBLE]?
>> Sorry?
>> What
do you consider
a fractals finite?
Say, fractals with the finite
area or the infinite.
>> We don't do that
in verification,
but I don't know about
fractals and that theory.
Here's a simpler setting
with first-order logic.
No recursive definitions and
no background theories.
This is pure first-order logic.
Is quantifying
instantiation complete?
And it turns out that it is.
So first consider pure
first-order logic.
And we're gonna do refutation
based, so negate it and
show unsatisfiability.
First, we skolemize and
we remove all existential
quantification by replacing
the functions, right?
And then we do systematic
formula driven term
instantiation, right?
So create an intuitively growing
conjunct of quantifier-free
formulas where and
every time you replace any
universal quantified
variable with any of
the terms that are current in
your formula so far, okay?
So more precisely,
let's say, we wanna show,
we have some kind of finite
axiomatization, A1 through An.
And lets say,
it's universally qualified.
And I wanna show naught phi
is implied by it, right?
So I negated then I saw I
have this formula to show as
unsatisfiable, right?
Then what I do is
I start with phi,
the thing which I wanna prove
under the axiomatization, right?
And that every time I take the
universally quantified formulas
and I instantiated using a term
in what I had before, right,
in Xn, right?
So that every time I get a
quantifier-free formulas, right,
and the X* is the union.
If I go on forever, X* is
the union of all of that, okay?
And indeed, it's true that this
is a complete procedure if I
generate Xn iteratively and
I check, right,
whether it's satisfiable.
If it is unsatisfiable, there
will be some point at which I
halt and
find it up to be unsatisfiable.
This is a combination
of Herbrand's theorem.
So Herbrand's theorem really
says that you can always build
a universe with only your terms.
Once you skolemize, you can only
build it with your terms, right?
And you need to what we had
to do was slightly modify it.
Because this is really driven
by the formulas that you have.
The instantiation is
driven by the formulas.
So you had to kind
of prove it again.
And then compactness, so
with Herbrand's theorem,
you really get X* that the set
of all things will be unsat.
And then by compactness theorem
for first-order logic, right,
we actually get that at some
point, Xn, it must hold, okay?
So quantify instantiation
works really well for
first-order logic.
Okay, now,
let's move to many-sorted
first-order logic, right?
So this is a setting
which we had to define,
because it's kind of
best fit are, yeah.
>> Can you go back?
So there's something on
local theories, right?
Local theories [INAUDIBLE],
local still related to that or?
>> I think so, but I'm not sure.
Maybe we can take it offline?
>> Mm-hm.
>> Yeah, so here, I have
a foreground universe, right?
So I have many sorts, right?
I have a foreground universe
which is uninterpreted, and
I have a background theories
that are interpreted.
So this could be arithmetic,
sets, whatever you will, right?
So I have a set of
background theories.
But it's very important that
these sorts are completely
disjoint, right?
>> And what I have is
a universally qualified formula,
right, over this vocabulary,
right?
And I have uninterpreted
functions that kind of map
across these available
vocabularies, okay?
And a rough idea is that I'm
gonna model my heap here, right,
these locations
are modelled here.
And maybe a function from here
to integers will tell me what
data is stored there, right?
A function from a pair of
locations could tell me
the heaplet that is
characterized by the less
segment or
some data structure and so on.
So roughly,
this is going to be the logics
that, it's kind of uninterpreted
world the program configuration
that I'm looking at.
But the contents of the program
configuration in terms of
primitive data types are gonna
be kind of captured using
the background theories.
Now, so this is the world we
want to belong to, right?
And then I wanna take this
formula which is only
universally quantified,
the ultimost quantifications
only of the foreground universe.
Because I will want to talk
about my program configuration
using universal quantification.
And internally, I could have
more quantification which is In
the respective theories, right?
Let me just allow that, but
the outer quantification
is on the foreground.
And now, I could ask
the same question, right?
I could fix some theories and
I could say,
I could do quantify
instantiation, right?
And when I do quantify
instantiation,
these variables
will be replaced.
But I'm not gonna touch also,
right?
So I'm just gonna do quantifier
instantiation in my foreground
universe, all right?
And I ask whether that
term instantiation
is actually complete, right?
Now, the background theories,
if I had the axioms for
them, I could do instantiation
using those axioms as well, and
then everything
will be complete.
But I don't want to do this.
I really want to use
Black Book service here.
So I don't wanna start
instantiating here, right?
Arithmetic should be solved
by an arithmetic solver.
And it turns out that
this is not true, right?
There are simple examples
that demonstrate this.
But quantifier instantiation,
just doing blindly
on the foreground,
is not going to be complete.
And the reason is that the
background theory can actually
restrict the foreground
theory in ways
that will preclude you from
finding the proof if you just
look at the terms that you get
by instantiating the foreground.
So their main technical
result we is that quantifier
instantiation is complete
in this setting for
what are called safe formulas or
safe fragment.
And this is very easy
to understand what they
say fragment is.
So a term is called
foreground guarded.
Okay, notice
the foreground universe.
So a term is called foreground
guarded if contains
variables only of
the foreground sort.
And the formula is safe if
every subterm that you have is
guarded, right?
Which basically means that
you cannot derive a term in
the foreground universe.
Right?
Using functions over universally
qualified variables in
the background.
You can't say there's
a list associated with or
a location associated
with an integer.
You can go the other way around,
right, but
you can't come back to the.
How does it related to
essentially uninterpreted
fragments?
>> Essentially uninterpreted
fragment doesn't have
background theories, typically.
But it is true we can prove the-
>> It does allow
background theory. Yeah.
>> Yeah so
if you have two thoughts
it'll allow right.
So we can prove as a corollary
the UF thing as well.
The beneficial class as well.
>> So this
>> Generalizes the graph
>> Yes, yes.
>> So, there are two simple
restrictions that you can follow
to meet the fragment's
conditions.
One is not to have
functions that go from
the background sort to
the foreground sort.
If you don't have any functions,
there's no way you can
construct anything.
Anything wrong.
If you had only forward
function than it's fine.
The other way is to
have no explicit
universal quantification
on the background.
If you say I won't quantify
integers explicitly then also
you're fine, because you're
then not gonna generate this.
When in practice what we
found is that The VCs that we
generate on heaps actually
need both the conditions.
You need to meet only one, but
it meets actually
both the conditions.
You don't need to quantify
our integers, right?
You quantify all
the elements of a list, and
then you can look at the keys
associated with that, but you're
still using a forward function,
and you're not quantifying over.
So if you want to say that two
lists have the same length?
>> Same what?
>> Two lists, if you want to say
two lists have the same length?
>> Yeah, so
you'll have a length function
which is recursively defined.
Now we can't define length
with first order logic yet.
Then you would say
that the length
of these two functions
are the same That's fine,
length is a function which
goes from nodes to integers.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
that's why.
[INAUDIBLE]
it's not uncommon
to quantify over the at
particular positions, right?
>> Right.
So array is a little
bit done differently,
you will have a program array
names, let's a or whatever.
Then you'll have
a function that maps a and
an index to some value.
And that's okay So
you can have, you're
domain can be a cross product
of any of the universes, right?
That's fine.
But your range has to be
always background one.
So now rate can be
defined this way as well.
>> I typically want
to go from array and index-
>> Yes.
>> To say-
>> A value.
>> Location or value or
something, right?
>> So that's right.
That's fine because that's
the location is not
necessarily background, right?
>> If you have a pointer as
in a true pointer as in like
an integer thing, that's harder.
I'm talking about here pointer,
locations being
abstract locations.
>> So if you have A sub,
B subject like,
we're using an array to
index another array.
>> Yeah, you need.
You can do that too but.
Yeah, so-
>> You can?
>> Yeah, but you don't have to,
you don't write it the same way.
But you can do it.
>> So
there you're using the array
content as a pointer
into another array?
>> You don't write it that way,
you can model it differently.
So that So, you still
>> Yeah.
Okay.
So I would then want to go
into the proof of the main
where I'm gonna look
at some ramifications.
One is that, if you do not have
Any quantification of
the background theory, then term
instantiation gives you only
quantified free formulas, right.
And over the background
theory if they are nice and
have the [INAUDIBLE] combinable
then you can actually have
a decision procedure.
And this decision procedure,
not a decision procedure,
complete procedure Right?
The complete procedure
will just do this.
Repeat till it's unsatisfiable.
Do one more level of term
instantiation and check whether
that set on instantiation
holds or not, right?
And this actually gives you
a complete procedure for
the safe fragment, okay?
Now, though the first thing we
had when we had the result is
that this must be wrong.
All right, because surely if
I have a background theory
of natural numbers.
I can define list a finite list,
and
therefore recur a least
fixed point easily
using arithmetic as
a background theory.
So I can have, I can say a nil
is a list, it's length is zero.
And then a non-nil
element is a list,
if the next of x is a list.
And that is one, length of x is
now one more than the other one.
You can define,
what you're doing, is you're
using recursion, but now you're
piggybacking your recursion on
the background theory,
which supports recursion, right?
But then this actually
goes wrong, right?
Because it lists numbers
as incomplete, right?
You can not build a complete
procedure for it, right?
So it will contradict our
completeness result if you can
actually do this, okay?
So what is going on
It turns out that
the whole thing has to do
with non-standard models.
All right, it turns out that
Presburger arithmetic though
a complete axiomatization right
admits non-standard models.
And your reasoning only with
respect to a background and
not a background model, right?
You don't have a two model.
You only.
So I could have this
kind of a list right?
Where x reaches,
I can claim x reaches nil but
it doesn't reach any finite
time, right, and to justify it
I could have the length function
map x to a non standard element
So nonstandard arithmetic is
where you have your normal,
natural numbers.
And let's say you can have
a copy of Z after that, okay?
And it turns out using first
order logic you cannot
distinguish between that and
just natural numbers, right?
But using that nonstandard
model I can actually Create one
which doesn't have
finite length and, so
you're encoding machines
to show incompleteness.
So, it's actually
in fact complete.
The result.
And it doesn't
contradict our theory.
So, now we also get a kind
of understanding of natural
proofs, right?
Formulas given in,
with least fixpoint, right.
Let say this is the definition,
right.
Now what you notice is that if
I gave you something with least
fixpoint definition, and
you just did unfolding on it.
Then really you do
not distinguish.
You're not capturing the least
fixpoints [INAUDIBLE] at all,
right, when you unfold.
If all that you're going to do
with your recursive definition
is to unfold it, then what
you're really treating it as
If and only if operator, right?
The fact that it's a least point
is kinda lost because you never
said anywhere that you're
gonna use it that way.
Okay, so
you can look at natural proofs
actually doing two things.
One is replace least fixed point
definitions with and if and
only if, right?
Now, this are semantic laws,
you're not [INAUDIBLE] point,
right?
And phase two is doing
quantify instantiation,
which is essentially doing
recursion definition unfolding.
And what we now know is
that This is actually,
I'm gonna argue now that phase
two is actually complete, okay?
And remember, for
completeness we need safety.
So I'm gonna argue
that what we're actually
generating is safe.
So it turns out that when
you model heaps, right,
you have locations now within
the foreground universe.
You have pointers modeled as
uninterpreted functions in
the foreground universe.
You have data stored
in data structures,
those go from foreground to
background like a key stored
in a data structure, right?
Recursive functions and
all are from, like sets of
keys in a data structure
in a binary search tree would be
from foreground to background.
Heaplets are foreground
to background.
And recursive definitions
like BST are predicates
which are defined using these
other functions, but are still
predicates on the foreground
which are uninterrupted.
>> My question still applies,
sorry.
If I have an array with indices,
and
indices are integers of
the background, right?
So then I have a function
from the background theory to
the contents of the array
which is foreground.
>> So it's array crossed
into integers to integers?
>> No, I re-cross integers to
something in the foreground like
values.
>> To values?
So we are not doing font,
we are now doing locations as
two locations that you can do
point arithmetic on
the abstract locations?
>> I mean, let's say,
I have an array of tuples.
>> Right.
>> Okay, so I have a function
from array cross integer, two
pairs, two [CROSSTALK] something
in the foreground, right?
So, that doesn't seem
to respect this,
>> Okay, so
maybe I've not
thought about that.
Maybe it's true, it's possible.
So in the natural proof
work we don't do that.
We don't have arrays.
We deal with purely
recursive data types, right?
And that's the context which
I'm saying that this is true.
So arrays, we do consider in
paper, but that's only for
the decidable fragments.
So we also get decidability
results on the way.
So there might be things which
we cannot model yet, right?
>> So if you have lists of
lists, can you model that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> But the point is, I mean,
you're not doing arithmetic
on it, but you're just doing.
So these are actually safe,
right?
Because you have
one-way functions.
And you don't need
quantification on integers
typically, right?
So it's actually safe by
the outer condition as well.
And so,
we actually have this term
instantiating that we do for
natural proofs, and that work
is actually complete, right?
Because it belongs
to a same fragment.
Provided you have replaced least
fixed point with fixed point
definitions.
So this phase is actually
complete, right?
And there is a semantic
gap introduced in Phase 1.
So why can't we prove things?
In natural proofs,
there are lots of simple
things we cannot prove.
And the user has to
give axioms for it.
But our work, it usually turns
out that if you define two data
structures, the relation
between them is typically not
provable and
you actually give that.
And you have a disjoint
list y then you get list x.
If you unfold,
you'll never be able to
prove this theorem, right?
And it turns out that
the reason is the Phase 1,
that semantic distance is
the one, and again non-standard
model is the reason why you
get into this problem, right?
The reason why you
can't prove it Is
because it's not actually
true in the if and
only if semantics of list
segments and list, right?
There's a semantic gap between
least fixed points and
fixed point semantics, right?
So this is actually,
if you had x,
even though it never reaches y,
right?
This is the next relation, never
reaches y, it can declare y to
be a list segment as long as I
declare all of these to be list
segments, right, I can still do
that and there's a model for it.
So we couldn't prove it,
because it wasn't valid
in the first order world.
So nonstandard models crop up
all the time in this work.
We found problems in
the literature and
PhD theses and so on.
There were theorems which
are now actually again open.
Because of this,
I won't comment on this.
>> So all this stuff
around shape analysis and
logics with the reachability
predicate is
assuming a least fixed
point semantics.
>> Yes.
>> Right, and so
you are abstracting
somehow over that.
>> Yes.
>> So what is your abstraction?
>> It's a fixed point and
not a least fixed point.
So when you're doing unfolding
[INAUDIBLE] if and only if.
>> All these logics of certain
restricted forms of heap for
which you can have completeness,
right?
So I'm trying, so how would,
so he has abstractions for
that, or
he has classes of logic.
So I just wonder what
is the relation here
between all the stuff have done?
Where they basically don't
have any background theories,
but they have just very hard
problems because of reachability
and the heap.
>> Right.
>> Those fall into your other
class of being increasingly
idiosyncratic logic fragments.
>> I see, okay.
>> So, I mean, I think there
ought to be a name for
this phenomenon, that the harder
you push on the decidability
boundary, the more idiosyncratic
your logic and models become.
>> Okay, so I think I'm running
out of time, so is that correct?
>> Ten minutes.
>> Okay, so I wanna tell you
a little bit with fixed points,
because what we have essentially
done is removed least
fixed points and
said everything works well.
But what with least
fixed points.
And the idea is that how are we
gonna prove these things after
all if we are not going to do
this unfold and match, right?
So this brings to this
other part which is, so
remember that first order logic
with least fixed point cannot
have a complete procedure,
right?
So anything that you introduce
is going to look like
a heuristic, right?
And what we do is we introduce
induction principles, right?
That bridge this gap between
least fixed point and
fixed point, okay?
And we do this kind of
uniformly, systematically,
guided by the formula that
we wanna prove, okay?
And obviously this has got to
do with invariant generation as
well, because a program is just,
you an look at it as first order
logic with least fixed points,
the entire program, right?
And so you're proving now that
whole program is correct without
loop invariants now, right?
So you're actually generating
loop invariants by doing these
induction principles.
The the crucial thing
is that we have to stay
within the first of
logic framework, right?
Induction principles are
typically second order, right?
But you wanna kind of stay in
the first order logic framework.
And in some way we're
instantiating the formulas that
we want to declare our
inductive systematically.
So we have some in the paper,
right?
So I'll just give you one,
One is this, for every x,
if I have to show that r(x)
implies psi(x) where R has
some definition phi R.
It is the recursive definition
which is using least fixed
point, okay?
And then what I do is introduce
this induction principle which
basically says that the partial
fixed point of this operator,
right?
If psi, right,
what I want to prove is
a pre-fixed point of
the definition of R,
then r implies phi.
Okay?
This is essentially saying
that whatever I want to prove,
I'm going to prove that
inductively based on
the definition of art, right?
I'm gonna show and formally this
becomes a prefix point, right?
So if I can show the size
of pre-fixed point, of row,
row is the definition of R,
right?
Then R implies psy,
I mean that is true, right.
And this brings in the least
fixed point semantics
into picture, right?
But the induction principle
is completely first order.
There's no mention of
these fixed points.
There are slightly more gentle
versions in this paper, but
the most important
thing is to show,
is to see that it is guided by
the formula you wanna prove.
You write it in this form that
this recursively defines object
implies something else, and then
you generate this automatically.
And then introducing this
induction principle in turn
leads to other induction
principles to be added.
So you will add one induction
principle like this one, and
then this might have something
else and that will introduce,
if you regroup it, right,
you can see it of this form and
you can instantiate one more
of another kind, right?
You can kind of keep going and
actually,
some examples actually require
that, that you do that.
And then what we showed is that
all the things that we could not
prove in natural proofs, right?
All the things where user
needed, lemmas, right?
The user needed to give
lemmas to help it to prove.
We're all proved using
a couple of these induction
principles, okay.
There were not too many axioms,
right?
There were about 150 programs,
but these have got to do only
with the data structure and
not with the programs, right?
And there are simple things like
if the if binary search tree,
then it's a binary tree, right?
You can't prove that
using unfolding, right?
>> So, Dr. John has
a couple of papers on this.
>> Yes, so that is correct.
So that's in the CLP
framework and, right.
So is a little-
>> That's separation and
logic, correct?
>> Right, so the key thing
here is that you're doing in
the first round of
logic framework, right.
So that once you do this you
know you can build a complete
procedure after that, right.
We also tried it
on some programs
which are not to do
with the heaps like.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yes, exactly.
I mean the same thing we did,
it addresses the same.
So we prove some things like
McCarthy 91 for example,
it proved it in two iterations.
it was able to find the right
loop on their end, right, and
actually prove it correct.
So this is what emerges, right?
If you wanna do natural proofs,
then one thing is to
take first order logic or
least fixed point which I think
is a good logic to work with.
Right, replace fixed
point definitions with,
fixed point definitions, right.
But use induction principles
to bridge this gap otherwise,
you're not gonna get
the power you need.
And the second phase is, unfold
and do quantified instantiation.
And this part is in
fact complete, right?
You must ensure
safety along the way.
So I don't know whether array
of pointers will work, right?
But this is only if you can
ensure safety is the complete as
result true, okay?
And if you further ensure that
the resulting formulas when you
instantiate terms
are qualify free.
Then you have the ability to use
assembly solvers with various
theories and you'll combine
because they quantify free and
by also they'll combine, so
you'll have something which
should work fast, right?
So work fast in the settings
we have tried, but
in general it should work fast.
Okay, so that's it, so
conclusions, a new theorem that
proves completeness of term
instantiation for multisorted
uninterpreted combination of
theories for the safe fragment.
And then the systematic
introduction of first order
induction principles
that seem to work,
in some settings at least.
And I think with these two,
we have an understanding and
a robust reformulation of this
completely ad hoc strategy
that we were doing.
Which is take everything,
expression first your
logic six point.
Just unfold,
it seems to work, right?
And it seem to work
was gotten from
who's the people on writing and
we thought,
they are such simple proofs,
why don't we use them, right?
So but now, I think we have
a more robust understanding of
what exactly is happening.
Okay, and there is a paper by
Gian Damora and this is actually
very similar, we found it
after we did this paper, but
it's very similar and
very different at the same time.
So the basic difference is that
it's not a multisorted universe,
right, and
then the logic that for
which you can prove the theorem
become very restrictive, right.
You can't even take two
universally quantified variables
and check equality between them.
Right, because equality is not
a interpret symbol, right, and
they won’t allow that.
Right, in fact, you can’t really
the proof is all different.
Even the first theorem
that I said for
first order logic
being complete.
Without any background theories,
even that doesn't go through
in that setting, so.
And of course there's
a huge amount of work in
finding induction principles in
the theorem proving community,
ACL too did a lot of work,
right?
We're probably mimicking such
strategies in that first order
logic world.
Right, but what we do have is
this completeness thing, and
production to SMT and
using SMT source.
So future work,
I would like to build,
SMT-like solvers being
efficient solvers for
first order logic with
least fixed points, right,
I think there'll be a lot of
applications, because first
order logic least fixed points
is incredibly powerful, right?
The second thing is,
we don't know these
induction principles for
how will they work for programs
that do not involve heaps?
We don't know.
It's probably easy to try
it on and see how it works.
But, we were little surprised
that McCarthy did not take 100
iterations, right?
He just took two iterations and
out popped the invariant and
that was a little surprising.
So we should investigate
that and of course,
how does it compare, right?
Because all these are gonna be
incomplete techniques, right,
how do they compare
with other techniques,
such as interpolation,
would be good to know.
The third thing is, I think
first order logic with least
fixed point and background
queries may be the right logic
to do for host style reasoning
or deductive verification.
All right, we certainly need
this much power, right?
We need data structures and
also,
in general, we need this kind
of power to do expressiveness
of the weakest pre.
There's a paper by Blass and
Gurevich actually that,
a long time back, that argues
that we actually should do this,
because you don't
need arithmetic.
You don't have to show
something complete by mapping
everything to arithmetic with
addition and multiplication for
which you don't have any thought
[INAUDIBLE] that's how most
completeness proofs go.
Right, but actually with
first order logic and
least fixed point you can
get that power to express
the weakest pre of any program
including loops, right?
And that maybe is useful, right?
And we do have now some ways of
handling first order logic or
least fixed point automatically.
The third thing is we probably
don't need much more.
I'm not sure about that.
I'm little hesitant to go beyond
first order logic because I just
don't know how to deal with
automation beyond first
order logic.
And I don't have compactness,
I don't have completeness.
I don't know term instantiation,
I know nothing to work with So
it's going to be very hard to
go beyond first order logic,
at least for me.
So maybe this is a good
logic to work with.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So
you started out talking about
the importance of decidability.
And then mostly what you said
was actually about completeness.
So what about decidability?
In other words,
if I have completeness, I don't
necessarily get countermodels.
And if I'm actually doing
a proof, countermodels
interactively, countermodels
are very important.
We use them for refining
adoptive hypotheses and we use
them when things are going wrong
and we have to understand why.
So under what circumstances
can I get countermodels?
>> I think countermodels you
could do by symbolic guest input
generation, right?
You could bound your heap,
you could bound things and
then get countermodels.
>> What if there is no
finite countermodel?
[CROSSTALK]
>> It’s just that I don’t know
whether.
It would be a finite,
your program configurations
are intended to be finite.
So they should be
a finite countermodel.
>> Well, yeah, maybe, but
once I sort of abstracted it
into the logic-
>> No, no without abstraction,
in the same way that
you just prove a VC,
you could try it for-
>> Standard model, so
as you said.
>> [LAUGH] I hope you don't
want nonstandard models as
a counterexample, right?
So I'm just saying that-
>> What I'm saying-
>> Just normal symbolic
execution should
do countermodels.
[CROSSTALK].
>> These are countermodels
to the invariance.
>> Yeah, but right, I don't want
a countermodel to my program.
I want the countermodel
to my VC.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's not the same thing.
>> Yeah,
countermodel to your VC.
You could do-
>> Because I've got
an extraction.
When I've got to my point
of having my VC attached,
obstruction, for example,
I got rid of these fixed points,
semantics or whatever.
So if I send my VC into
my theorem proover and
it should either eventually
come back with a proof,
or it should eventually come
back with a countermodel.
In which case you
have decidability.
>> I just think that these two
procedures might be totally
different.
If you wanna prove something
versus fine count examples,
these may be different things.
>> Right, but they're not-
>> Because we cannot possibly
target finding complex
counter-examples, and
finding simple proofs at
the same time, right? So-
>> I think you're missing my
point about the usefulness
of countermodels.
>> No, I'm not saying that,
I'm just saying that you can do
countermodels by some
other technique.
>> Well, no no,
if you could do that,
then your logic
would be decidable.
Because if I can get
countermodels, if countermodels
are RE and if proofs are RE-
>> Proofs are not RE,
they're gonna have at least six
point, they're not gonna be RE.
>> Right, but
let's say I've [INAUDIBLE]
least six point semantics.
>> Then it is complete,
it is decidable, yes, I agree.
In fact,
I'd argue that the program
configurations are innumerable.
It's satisfiable, it is an RE.
So if you've done
away with this-
>> We have to talk about
this offline.
Cuz we [CROSSTALK]
misunderstanding.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, [LAUGH]
>> Let's thank.
>> [APPLAUSE]